the queen's gambit is a best-selling novel written
in 1983 by walter tevis it covers the life and
times of an orphan chess prodigy named beth harmon
as she rises through the ranks and deals with a
troubling past and substance abuse issues it's a
book that was recently brought to the big screen
if you will in an original netflix mini series
seven episodes to be exact and i'm here to discuss
all that it was with the one and only good friend
of mine women's grand master jennifer shahani
two-time u.s women's champion and author of
the book chess [ __ ] as well as with aaron
hawaii who is chess.com's esports producer a
lot of you know that so he's kind of an expert
on what we believe chess entertainment
should be and he's also an amateur chess
player who's played in a few chess tournaments
himself hi and all right how you guys feeling
great we're really excited to be here like
everybody's buzzing about this netflix series
queen's gambit so it's fun to get a chance to
talk about it with you guys well on the no the
first question i have is okay we're talking about
this mini-series i i assume we've all had a chance
to see at least a few episodes right aaron
how many episodes have you seen at this point
i think i've seen three so far so this is
great you'll be able to spoil it for me okay
well that'll be great spoiler alerts ahead right
and jen you were just saying you've seen all the
episodes but a couple of them you were distracted
by the end but you you also read the book oh yeah
and i mean it was so grippy and the only reason
i was distracted i was trying to rush through
it for this and my son you know sometimes took me
away but it was it was incredibly ripping spoiler
alert it was so good i'm not i'm not gonna tell we
don't have to give all the details away but it was
just very grippy it's easy to binge well i want to
start with you jen and ask because you've read the
book how do you feel the adaptation was from the
book to the netflix miniseries do you feel they
stayed true and all the elements that were that
were appropriate to stay true to what would be
your thoughts quickly on the book edit adaptation
itself you know i've read the book a long time
ago when i was a kid inspired to be a great chess
player so i remember um vaguely the book but i am
about to reread it because at us chess women we're
going to do this this new book club about like
books related to either chats or like intellectual
growth and that's our first book so i'm excited
to reread it but listen the adaptation was so
phenomenal that it's hard to imagine anything
being much better so like the book might be as
good i can't imagine it being much better it's
just it seems from like a filmmaking perspective
they they nailed so many elements right well
to talk about the the actress that plays the main
character over to you aaron so how what did you
think of anya taylor joy's performance right
we've seen her in other things recently was in
it was in emma but what were your thoughts
on on her performance overall and you feel
she did a good job from your perspective um and
maybe a little more new to the chess community
than me and jen as far as uh really really
portraying what a chess prodigy would be like
well definitely an aspect of one of the
earlier episodes that i identified with
uh was the experience she had going to her
first tournament and just being like what am
i supposed to do with this where do i go right
when do i press that you know like i had that
experience myself at the um my first tournament
in the north american open in vegas last year
um and and that's that's what it's like but she
expressed a confidence that i definitely did not
have in my first tournament um after getting all
of that training from the the custodian that if
you haven't seen the series yet you'll meet in the
first episode um but uh taking to it so much more
naturally and then showing that confidence when
she arrived that i think is really important for
a show like this or a movie like this where uh
something like chess is used as the premise that
brings all these people together is i like to ask
myself if it wasn't chess if it was something else
uh would this story still be as strong and i
think the answer for this show is definitely yes
obviously we love it because we also
love chess and that brought us there
um but the performances and the photography
and just all of the other aspects of this show
make are so great that this could be about
something else and it still has legs because of
things like that and obviously the awesome casting
that you mentioned right well all right aaron
talked a little bit about the the first chest
from experience but jenna you can speak more
than anyone in this call obviously about what it's
like to be a woman chess player obviously in the
chess community and what were your thoughts on on
taylor joy's performance as far as uh expressing i
mean aaron says she had a lot of confidence right
and also the experience of being a woman in a
very male dominated environment right what were
your thoughts on some of the struggles she went
through as a k in her character and do you feel
like that adaptation as a real life woman chess
prodigy player right which is who you who you
are and were how do you feel like that came
across and did you relate with any of tho any
of the feelings she had and anything you would
say about her character sort of growth throughout
throughout the series yeah i mean i thought that
first of all i don't come into chess movies or
poker movies like looking for um a completely
realistic portrayal like i'm after getting
into the spirit of chess what makes us
love it and i think that she certainly nailed
that anya killer joy i've seen some interviews
with her talking about her preparation for you
know this role and i frankly from what i've seen
i think she's a genius like i think she's
absolutely brilliant and i think that's why
she took this world so well because obviously
she's portraying a brilliant um young woman
um and yeah she you know she has some
gender specific like hurdles like you know
getting her first period at a chess tournament
and things like that spoiler alert oh my god
i gave away a keyboard you gave
away the whole movie no i'm kidding
seriously um she on the other hand she's so strong
it almost feels like an asset because it makes her
i'm so separate from everyone else she stands out
and her brilliance stands out and i think that
she kind of uses it to her advantage in a way
as she feels special and she is special right um
and she doesn't really play any other women in the
movie that there's one right in the very beginning
yeah the first one she beats yeah and even like
the people she plays blitz with like the simul
so if you count it there might be like 50
people she's played chess with in the movie
i mean i didn't count but i would say
maybe 50 to 60. so she plays one woman
and 50 to 60 men and if the movie has any flaw
from like uh i would say like to me like a
conceptual point of view because i think it was
almost perfectly done as a piece of art um from
a concept point of view like if you want to think
of it as like a feminist film and i mean you don't
have to but if you want to think of it as feminist
series it certainly works in that way in a certain
way because it's this like brilliant young woman
who's also interested in fashion and a free spirit
but the fact that other women it's kind of like
her at the very top so she's a genius right which
is a character that's usually occupied by a male
she's like the mad woman genius right right um
and then there's all the men underneath that who
are like smart of different levels of intelligence
and then there's underneath that other women right
right and like that that is not might come off as
a harsher criticism than it sounds because it
also was set in the 60s right right i think so
it's like it's not like they're saying these
women are dumb it's just that none of them have
any interest in chess and the ones that do have
an in-person chest aren't good enough to play
even the people that she crashes right so being
like a big promoter of girls and women in chats
that was like the one thing like you know this
pop song most girls right it's like is is beth
an example that any woman can do anything
or that there might be some women out there
that are exceptional and are actually even
better at men at the types of things men do
yeah it's a lot of food for thought and i agree
with your uh your breakdown of the the different
messages i guess you could take from it depending
on what your perspective is but giving the
perspective of chess players i want to ask both of
you i think that was one of the most interesting
things for me but i'll start with you aaron as
a as a less experienced chess player right but
what did you think of the chess adaptation itself
right there the scenes of the chess uh what what
did they what did they speak to you in regards to
how realistic they were and and uh and then i'll
ask the same question to jen in terms of how much
you enjoyed that well one of my favorite moments
uh concentrating specifically on the chess in the
show was uh i think maybe in the third episode
where she's asked to think back on a previous game
that she played and so she goes to sit down to a
board and begins to set up a position from memory
uh with the pieces before i started really trying
to learn chess if somebody else did that in front
of me i was just kind of blown away like how could
you remember a position like that and just set
it up just from memory like without diagrams or
whatever what's funny is that um once i started to
take take chess more seriously and prepare to play
in tournaments for the first time i found myself
myself able to do that able to recall clusters of
positions and games that i had just played to
set it back up and try to think about it again
like in ways that that i would have been amazed
by in the past and then i became the person other
people were like wait you can do that you
can remember what happened in that game um
and and so i think not just like the accuracy of
specific sequences that were shown in the film as
you know whether or not they're accurate chess
but more of like i appreciated the accuracy of
what that's all like the awe of being able
to be so focused on your chess learning
that the the culture that kind of exists around
people like that uh setting up games and talking
about them with your opponents afterwards or or
just challenging each other to rethink things
um they definitely captured that right jim what
were your thoughts on i guess both the the chess
x's and o's right appreciating and maybe what
was the first chess position you recognized
that was famous um and and your thoughts
on what are instead about did they really
capture what the feeling is for you as a as a
professional and two-time us women's champion well
um i thought that bruce pandelfini and gary
kasparov as chronicled in the new york times
did a really fantastic job with the the chest
scenes and like the chest positions um i
agree with rn that it was also about like the
spirit of it like the way she gets so excited
when she learns a new opening from the custodian
or you know she hears about the sicilian like that
was very striking to me how well they did that and
i thought she also did a really good job with the
blitz chest because that's extremely difficult to
do for an actor and what interests me is that in
interviews i discovered that she has a background
as like a model and an actress i mean and sorry
obviously she's an actress as a dancer so she
mentioned that the choreography of dancing really
helped her with being able to like you know the
choreography of your hands and like making these
chest moves quickly um and you know particularly
like where she gets a blitz simultaneously like
this party where everybody's drinking and
she does a little time all right um and
she said that that she was incredibly proud of
herself for pulling that off and i actually did
an art project once with a dancer friend of mine
gabrielle revlock we did something called hulicha
where were you hula hoop you see my hoop in the
background and played chess at the same time
and i had to teach her how to play chess so
that she looked like a chess player but it
was a memorized game um and she also did way way
better than like most people and i think it's that
that dancer's training that you're looking for
these microscopic movements in the hands that
other people might not see and like in the whole
body and the elbows um and she i thought really
hooked me with her bliss performances well and
i'll say i observed that i i actually think that
and i don't know if this is factual in terms
of how they filmed that i felt like she
got even better as it went on which also
represented her character there is some unsureness
at first with the hands as a chess player when
they're learning but i feel like as it went on
you could see the confidence and something that
i always look for whenever i'm watching chess
uh shows in terms of the confidence in which you
watch a video with carlson and nakamura and they
move with no hesitation right and you can see
the difference between players that do that
versus some unsureness right and i think that
everybody in their role did a pretty good job
with that for sure and i just noticed that the
white square was always on the right right so they
they never messed up the chess the chess
was beyond and i would say it's probably
the best chess i've seen in any anything on film
since uh since the searching for bobby fischer
movie and on that note i have to ask was
beth harmon supposed to be bobby fisher
is that who the character is based on what
did you what did you guys take from that
or in first um i don't know if it was necessarily
meant to represent somebody uh who is an actual
you know person other than maybe the author
because i i think i read somewhere that
the author of the book actually had a similar sort
of experience in youth with drug addiction that
was forced upon him or something like that
but um i think maybe she's an amalgamation
of different people not just in the history
of chess but just in the history of excelling
at something to the point of of becoming
famous from it and right and the pressures
that come from that the inner struggle that
comes from that um sometimes the inability to
to listen to the input of others right who
are outside of that but seeing you go through
something right uh i think that's pretty common
among these types of of people in real life and
so the all of that ends up being distilled into
this one character yeah jen your thoughts on that
um yeah i think that there's definitely
some references to bobby fischer
in the movie but there i agree completely with
um aaron that it's like some kind of composite
you know there you see i think there was some
suggestion that there were some gary kasparov
references in her character i got
some judah polgar even honestly
judith diana lanny actually who um apparently in
some of the same circles as walter kevis she just
wrote in my my wall in a post about this that
um she heard that there were some references
to her because she did struggle with some some
of the same things that bec did in the movie
and so i think uh yeah that it was an incredible
character but i don't think it was like based on
one person i did notice in your notes you had
a specific thought about judith polgar that
perhaps the the hair color was a reference right
was it was a direct homage i i didn't know right
just because i i haven't read the book right
so i wasn't sure if the hair color was a direct
reference to the red the red hair of jennifer
jihadi that's that it was me it was you i did see
an interview with her talking about that danny so
i can clear it up the hair was brown in the book
and the red hair in the movie was her right or the
series rather was her idea to make her stand out
from all the other characters i mean not that
being a a beautiful woman was not enough because
all men but also nobody else in the movie
had red hair so it's like that second layer
of like wow she totally panned out but yeah
of course you can't help when you're watching
it to think about judith pogar is like flaming
red hair and like what it represents speaking
of standing out was the cowboy hat too much
i mean aaron okay i think the guy's wearing
a hat that might be a little too much orange
go ahead cowboy hat too much i think there
need to be more hats and chests okay there you
go well you're referring it what did you think
i felt like there was a little bit of an eccentric
nod to that to the eccentric chess-obsessed guy
right and and as something maybe the cowboy had
for the writing kind of brought that out but
what was your thought on the outfit that uh that
benny watts sported throughout the entire series
i liked it i think the movie was fantastic and
moody and i liked that benny represented like a
little bit of injection of humor like he was like
the one character that was just kind of like pop
you know like earth little here's a little humor
and i actually wish the movie had a tiny bit more
of that right so whenever he came on screen i was
like yeah because then we see the contrast of her
moody emotive acting and like just you know
almost like kind of similar to the drugs she's
taking right right kind of slows you down and then
this guy who's like not as talented as her but a
little bit more manic right right large larger
than life character i definitely related to the
sleeping on someone's floor in new york and having
to like grab some i mean i think a lot of chess
players have been there um well all right i got i
got a lot more questions we can get to and one of
the things i wondered is we're all talking about
this as chess players me and eugene especially and
arin you're you're you're a chess professional
in a lot of ways now right but did you
did you watch with uh with your wife any non-chess
players with you and what were their thoughts on
it did you have that experience you know she
actually made fun of me when i queued it up
for the first episode you just want to watch
it because it's about chess but uh now she's
like she's so hooked on it because it's just an
excellent show regardless of the chess and so um
yeah i mean what was the original question what
did she think about it so she you answered it
she was hooked on it she liked it even as a
non-chess player and your your husband daniel
is not a chess player either right jen no and
he actually works in film so he had a lot of um
a lot of interesting thoughts on it um yeah he
he loved it he also binge it but he loves chass
so it's not and we did like some chess projects
together so it's not that surprising that he
really liked it but yeah he talked about it
also about this like it's almost like the show
is a male fantasy in a way because it's you know
it's about this female heroine and it's it works
both ways it works as like a a woman fantasy and
it's a male fantasy just like in a different way
just like the wanting to be with her and the
wanting to be her right those different angles
and i yeah i really i think that um the one thing
is i'm getting tons of messages because i'm like
a redheaded chess player who wrote chess [ __ ]
right so clearly there's like a lot of even though
i wasn't i wasn't um around when he wrote queen's
gambit there was no me in that i still like i'm
getting questions from people what do you think of
it do you like it were you involved at all right
and so i and these are people that don't play
chess at all um just you know friends from from
high school college poker all over the place and
invariably people are like i love it well we know
that there were a couple chess players involved
you mentioned gary kasparov and of course bruce
pandolfini and pandorfini himself makes a cameo in
episode six were there any other chess cameos that
i missed asking for a friend did anyone else see
any other chess gamers or was it just pandelfini
i think it was just him because it was shot in
berlin um yeah it was shot in berlin so there
there would be it would have to be it has to be
like a german chess player maybe we don't maybe we
wouldn't recognize them got it okay sorry i just
was curious if anyone else saw um we've got uh
so one of the one of the questions we got to ask
first is your favorite scene so far well i really
enjoyed um both when she learned how to play chess
from the custodian i thought he was like such a
magical character because it takes this kind of
understanding of chess as something that's totally
not hierarchical so they're playing chess in the
basement with somebody in a job that's usually
not as respected as it should be although now
with like kobe 19 we understand very much that
essential workers and keeping places like clean
is like basically one of the most important
things fundamentally in society right so yeah we
i think we're getting that a bit more but in the
movie it's like it's amazing how quickly chass
teaches you that because you never once think
of the custodian as somebody who's like lesser
right never even though he's in the basement and
because of like the lighting they also make the
basement look like this magical place not like
this dark and damp place right so from the
very beginning the movie just shows you like
this is the most beautiful place in in the world
right it's her favorite place for sure you get
you get that sense from the character and i think
that you know having played chess my whole life
that's one of the best parts about it right it
transcends age gender race religion right like
you said a transition it i always say that but it
also transcends hierarchical sort of stereotypes
and culture and if anything the custodian is
sort of a god-like almost father figure who's
one of the first nourishers she has right in some
ways he sort of helps sort of take care of her
but um anyway yeah that's a great point i would
ask on that note we've touched on some of the
non-chess controversial topics orange just said
one of his favorite scenes directly relates to
maybe something forbidden makes me wonder
how what age do you think is appropriate
for us to show this to young chess players
if we're looking for uh something to inspire
them a new chess prodigy story what age would you
say it's appropriate for someone to see it aaron
well uh being the parent of zero children i
uh i don't know if my opinion will actually be
accurate but i mean there's definitely some
things that um that would probably hinder
the kind of like positive messaging that you
might want to try to impart on your children
by asking having them watch the show with you
um so maybe they need to be i don't know like
getting close to high school age um but
but yeah i think i think it could be a good
story as long as you you know can
get past those things and just
and and show it to a child that you think is at
the right age to understand the real messages
right right overall you know message behind
this story rather than just focusing on
the individual moments because i think that's what
really shines about this right is is not just like
the individual moments but like just saying like
this is this can be what it's like to have to like
grow up and take care of yourself and like try
new things and and and and maybe just like uh
not worry too much if you stand out because you're
different or you're interesting or whatever right
that that that's not always a negative thing
i think there's some good messages there yeah
good position oh there's lots of great messages
but it's a really wonderful question danny and
it's something that i grapple with is like the
program director of us chess women because i
um see that to me the question is not you know
what age is appropriate for them to watch it but
they're gonna watch it you know so many teenagers
and free teams are gonna find a way to watch this
and then how do we deal with the fact that it
has like such an empowering message in one hand
but then also let's just be honest with let's not
fake it or any incredibly unrealistic um wrong
message about what tranquilizers or pills can do
for your chest skill right right there is no way
that downers are gonna help you protip everybody
that's not going to help you with chess go ahead
that is not going to make you a test genius it's
not going to unlock your genius that is completely
crazy and of course the show needs to introduce
conflict and drama so it's understandable why
they made that choice to go in that direction but
alcohol and downers seem like it would really be
like the worst thing for your child right um
and particularly now when we have like opioid
epidemics with you know fentanyl like people
just dropping dead because they take you know a
pill it's like i'm not going to be the one to give
you the revelation that drugs are bad right right
but it's like it's particularly with pills right
now and hopefully this will start to change in
like the next few years you know i i'm really
praying because you know i've lost people because
of bill's i'm sure most many people watching this
have um it's it's unfortunate to me but i think
that the reality is kids are super smart so you
got to be honest with them and explain to them
that like this is a beautiful series but that
part is fictional right that that kind of drug
is not going to unlock your genius right well
and maybe maybe definitely make it to the end
right where you know you learned that not every
uh drug story has to be a tragedy of of succumbing
but maybe one of triumph and overcoming right
and against spoiler alert if if you're if you
were looking for a horrible ending i think the
ending is actually amazing on that note i think
before we end this we have to ask so where does
this rank right it's a it's a great series it's
an adaptation but also i i always think of the
the best chess films of all time before i tell
you where i would rank it and maybe what kind
of stars i would give it i'll ask the two of
you where would you rank it among your favorite
chess film film film experiences of all time
number one put it personally at number one oh
really because for me um even though it does
strive and i think achieve a level of accuracy in
terms of like the actual chess that's shown in it
but it does that and tells an excellent story
outside of it whereas all of the other chess
you know themed movies and television shows that
i've watched um it's usually either you get one or
the other you get a lot of accurate chess being
shown but not a lot of engaging storytelling um
or just high quality production value which is
something i focus on or you get it the other
way around right it's very entertaining and very
inaccurate very well this one was just such a good
mix of both so i feel like i put it at
the top okay jen what about you yeah i
i have to say uh orange stole my ranking in that
i think i put it at number one too um because
of it i think it's a it's an unreal achievement
it's it's hard to imagine a depiction of chess
being um this beautifully executed and i think
a lot of credit must go to the acting and the
director for that they really seem to just like
allow it to rise above anything that i could have
hoped for that said it was seven hours long so i
think it's a bit of a apples and orange comparison
i loved queen of catway i thought that movie
was brilliant as well i loved brooklyn castle
so um i thought that for what its genre was it
was close to 10 out of 10. um and some of those
other movies i think were close to 10 out of 10
too but they were shorter so it's you know i'd
rather have seven hours of 10 out of 10 right than
like two hours of 10 out of 10. i you know as you
talk about i guess i'm maybe surprisingly agreeing
i think searching for bobby fischer to me at least
previously to this one took the cake of they got
the chest right right and i think that one of the
things you know regardless of the true story of
josh waitskin and uh and and his relationship with
bruce pandelfini whether that was close to real or
not didn't matter the movie itself with lawrence
fishburne the scenes in washington square park the
scenes of of the struggle of a young chessboard
i thought that was previous to this maybe the
closest this is a little more adult than that
but i would agree that because it's an apples
to oranges comparison seven hours of this is uh
i kept waiting for them to slip up and they never
quite did so i i think your your ranking of 10
out of 10 agrees with most of the people right
now raking it on rotten tomatoes and and with
that we'll encourage everybody that they should
definitely check it out and make sure you see
the queen's gambit right now on netflix and uh if
you don't mind give us give us your opinions and
comments down below let us know whether you agree
with some of our answers or or think we're nuts
we love it either way and while you're here give
us a like and a share and let us know what your
what your favorite scene from the queen's gambit
was so thank you so much for uh for checking out
our breakdown of the queen's gambit on netflix
and uh see you around on chess.com bye guys